one day the people that don't even
believe in you will tell everyone how
they meant you
when you build in silence
people don't know what to attack
loneliness is the price you pay when you
start to improve yourself
if someone is trying to bring you down
they are already below you
failure is a bruise not a tattoo
the truth is everyone is going to hurt
you
you just gotta find the ones worth
suffering for
turn your wounds into wisdom
if you look at the people in your circle
and you don't get inspired
you don't have a circle
you have a cage
a good life has some bad days too
don't cry because it's over
smile because it happened
when writing the story of your life
don't let anyone else hold the pen
smiling doesn't necessarily mean you're
happy
sometimes it just means you're strong
for it is better to be alone
than in Bad Company
free yourself from society's advice most
of them have no idea
of what they're doing
the family you create is more important
than the family you come from
how many things would you attempt if you
knew Ed not fail
if you aren't willing to work for it
don't complain about not having it
one day all those late nights and early
mornings will pay off
be valuable
not available
[Music]
things hardest to Bear our sweetest to
remember
the best thing I ever did was stop
telling people what's going on in my
life
words are like keys
if you choose them right
they can open any heart and shut any
mouth
if you only walk on sunny days
you'll never reach your destination
people inspire you
or they drain you
pick them wisely
allow yourself to be a beginner
no one starts off being excellent
do it alone
do it broke
do it tired
do it scared
just do it
never make a permanent decision based on
temporary feelings
life has many different chapters for us
one bad chapter doesn't mean it's the
end of the book
normality is a paved Road
it's comfortable to walk
but no flowers grow there
be proud
you survived the days you thought you
couldn't
you are at your strongest
when you are calm
judge no one
just improve yourself
train your mind to be stronger than your
feelings
don't over share
privacy is power
problems are not stop signs they are
guidelines
life is like a book
some chapters are sad some are happy
but all are necessary for the full story
the strongest people are not those who
show strength in front of us
but those who fight battles we know
nothing about
the pain you feel today
will be the strength you feel tomorrow
sometimes we're tested not to show our
weaknesses
but to discover our strengths
never tolerate disrespect
not even from yourself
worrying is like a rocking chair
it gives you something to do but gets
you nowhere
a ship is safe in Harbor
but that's not what shifts are for
foreign
chasing the wrong things the right ones
catch up
there is no elevator to success
you have to take the stairs
focus on you
people come and go
sometimes the things that break your
heart end up fixing your vision
your deepest darkest moment may be the
best thing that ever happens to you
learn to heal without venting to
everyone
time always exposes what you truly mean
to someone
you're being judged no matter what
so be who you want to be
if you are not falling down occasionally
you are just coasting
first it hurts
then it makes you stronger
work at your job and make a living
work on yourself and make a fortune
striving for Success without hard work
is like trying to harvest where you
haven't planted
if you don't let go of the wrong people
you'll never meet the right people
if you don't control your mind
someone else will
there will always be someone who doesn't
see your worth
don't let it be you
do what no one else can do
and you will become what no one else can
become
make more moves and less announcements
remember
five years ago you dreamed about being
where you are now
think about it
playing it safe is the most dangerous
thing you can do in life
never be embarrassed to struggle
there is absolutely no shame in working
hard to get to where you want to be
growing harder doesn't help if the boat
is headed in the wrong direction
you don't get paid for the hour
you get paid for the value you bring to
the hour
let the Improvement of yourself keep you
so busy that you have no time to
criticize others
guard well your thoughts when alone and
your words when accompanied
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
talking without thinking is like
shooting without aiming
do not go where the path may lead
go instead where there is no path and
leave a trail
the fact that you aren't where you want
to be
should be enough motivation
foreign
discipline is choosing between what you
want now and what you want most
stop telling people everything
most people don't care
and some secretly want you to fail
it's a slow process but quitting won't
speed it up
what comes easy won't last
what lasts won't come easy
don't ruin a good today by thinking
about a bad yesterday
Let It Go
success is what happens after you've
survived all your mistakes
winners focus on winning
losers focus on winners
before something great happens
everything falls apart
if someone tells you you can't they're
showing you their limits
not yours
if you live for people's acceptance you
will die from their rejection
there are two types of pains
one that hurts you and the other that
changes you
one day you'll see why God made you wait
for your peace of mind
don't let people know too much about you
if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
he's selfish with your time
a lot of people don't deserve it
silence is the best answer to someone
who doesn't value your words
fear is temporary
regret this forever
your future needs you
your past doesn't
don't get burned twice by the same Flame
worrying about losing is losing before
you begin
excuses make today easier but tomorrow
harder
discipline makes today hard
but tomorrow easier
don't give up
you are closer than you think
sometimes being alone is the best
medicine to your soul
we fall we break
we fail
but then we rise we heal
we overcome
sacrifice a few years of comfort
for decades of freedom
have patience
all things are difficult before they
become easy
don't let yesterday take up too much of
today
if you get tired
learn to rest
not to quit
the two most important days in your life
are the day you are born
and the day you find out why
hardship often prepares an ordinary
person
for an extraordinary destiny
positive thinking will let you do
everything better than negative thinking
will
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
your past is a place to learn and grow
not a place to live
don't rush the process
trust it
great things take time
Big Dreams require healthy habits
and healthy habits require
self-discipline
if you stay positive in a negative
situation
you win
sometimes you win
sometimes you'll learn
take a deep breath
it's just a bad day not a bad life
fall seven times
stand up eight
if you believe it will work out
you'll see opportunities
if you believe it won't
you will see obstacles
if you don't try
nothing will ever happen
don't give up on yourself
there's a reason why you started
be obsessed with becoming the best
version of yourself
when in your mind
and you will win in your reality
making mistakes is better than faking
Perfections
except what is let go of what was
have faith in what will be
the calmer you are
the clearer you think
the moment when you want to quit
it's the moment when you need to keep
pushing
control your thoughts or your thoughts
will control you
become a ghost
forget attention
just grow in private
push yourself to be your best
no one else is going to do it for you
focus on improving yourself
not proving yourself
two things Define you
your patience when you have nothing
and your attitude when you have
everything
don't quit
nothing lasts forever
not even pain
keep it private
until it's permanent
you only fail when you stop trying
you don't need more time
you need less distractions
everyone leaves
learn how to survive alone
value your peace of mind
you can't reach what's in front of you
until you let go of what's behind you
to be the best you must be able to
handle the worst
a goal without a plan is just a wish
wanting to be someone else
is a waste of Who You Are
if life were predictable
it would cease to be life
and be without flavor
life is like a coin
you can spend it any way you wish
but you only spend it once
practice self-compassion
we are all human
and everyone makes mistakes
Time Heals almost everything
give it time
sometimes you have to let go of
something good to make room for
something better
what other people think of you is none
of your business
you can't start the next chapter of your
life if you keep re-reading the last one
the best view comes after the hardest
climb
you'll never find a rainbow if you're
looking down
tough times don't last
but tough people do
you cannot change the direction of the
wind but you can adjust your sails to
reach your destination
there are no shortcuts to any place
worth going
a River cuts through Rock not because of
its power
but because of its persistence
you are confined only by the walls you
build yourself
focus on what you can control
and let go of what you cannot
the only time you should ever look back
is to see how far you've come
doubt kills more dreams than failure
ever will
in the face of adversity remember that
Diamonds Are Made under pressure
first step to getting anywhere is
deciding you're not willing to stay
where you are
the true test of a man's character is
what he does when no one is watching
don't go broke trying to impress broke
people
stay away from people who make you feel
lonely
no company is better than a Bad Company
don't compare your life to others
you have no idea what their journey is
all about
no one is going to figure out your life
it's your responsibility
life isn't fair
but it's still good
he who is not courageous enough to take
risks will accomplish Nothing in life
do yourself a favor
get rich life gets easier with money not
time
to avoid disappointment expect nothing
from nobody
stress is temporary but the lessons you
learn from it can last a lifetime
do your best and Trust the process
the harder you work the luckier you will
get
if you are a giver
remember to learn your limits because
the takers don't have any
you have three choices in life
you can watch things happen make things
happen
or wonder what the hell happened
no regrets just lessons
no worries just acceptance
no expectations
just gratitude
life is too short
the more you are interested in others
the more interesting they find you
to be interesting
be interested
we suffer more in imagination than in
reality
people change Love Hurts friends leave
things go wrong
but remember that life goes on
don't let anyone know what you're doing
until it's done
the only person that cares about your
hopes and dreams is you
the only person that is going to make
them happen
is you
forget what hurts you but never forget
what it taught you
mastering others is strength
mastering yourself is true power
your direction is more important
than your speed
never regret a day in your life
good days give happiness bad days give
experience
worst days give lessons
and best days give memories
life is short
live it love is rare
grab it anger is bad dump it
fear is awful
face it
memories are sweet
cherish them
don't depend too much on anyone in this
world
because even your own shadow leaves you
when you are in darkness
remember some of the best times of your
life haven't even happened yet
bad habits are like a comfortable bed
easy to get into but hard to get out of
no one is too busy it's only a matter of
priorities
if it keeps you happy
keep it quiet
be careful who you trust
salt and sugar look the same
time always exposes what you truly mean
to someone
stay calm
you've been through this before you'll
get through it again
if people treat you like an option leave
them like a choice
value experience over possessions
because memories are the real Treasures
of life
so many people love you
don't focus on the people who don't
your vision will be blurry
but it will grow clear with time
take care of your body
remember health is another form of
wealth
your strongest muscle and worst enemy is
your mind
train it well
don't react
cut them off silently
someone else's progress doesn't make
yours any less
small circle
private life
and peaceful mind
sometimes we create our own heart breaks
through expectation
Embrace Solitude as a time for
reflection and self-discovery
we have four problems overthink over
trust over share
over love
don't let anyone ever make you feel like
you don't deserve what you want
you grow mentally weak when your life is
too comfortable
just let it be
if it's meant to be it will happen
just be real it saves everyone's time
don't share your personal life with
anyone
do not let anyone have anything that
could harm you
the moment you let go of your discipline
is the moment you give up on yourself
done
is better than perfect
your worst enemy might just be someone
you trust the most
Beware of the wolves in sheep's clothing
sharing your accomplishments is
essential
but avoid the pitfall of over sharing
every Minor's success
life's most significant achievements
often emerge from the depths of
adversity
mistakes are Stepping Stones not
stumbling blocks
learn from them and move forward
self-care is not selfish
it's essential for a balanced and
fulfilling life
the value of time becomes evident when
it's gone
use it wisely
don't pretend to be better than you are
live life at your own pace
care about what other people think and
you will always be their prisoner
the possibilities are endless as long as
you don't limit yourself
set high standards for yourself and live
up to your own expectations
surround yourself with people who
inspire you to become even better
foreign
through life you'll miss all the good
stuff along the way
you choose to keep
says a lot about who you are
you are in charge of your own happiness
you don't need to wait for other
people's permission to be happy
stop doing what is easy or popular
start doing what is right
relax
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is capable
life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
don't bite off more than you can chew
because nobody looks attractive spitting
it back out
prioritize your physical and mental
health they are your most valuable
assets
don't be afraid to say I don't know
and seek knowledge from others
don't stop when you're tired stop when
you are done
do it now
sometimes later becomes never
when you are winning keep your mouth
shut
trying to create a new you around the
same old people
everything you do doesn't have to be
seen or heard
your words start to lose value when your
actions don't match
if there is no struggle there is no
progress
Falling Down is an accident
staying down is a choice
stop being okay with everything
only dead fish go with the flow
remove the clowns from your life before
you become one
stay quiet about your goals
soon your results will do all the
talking
everything is going to be all right
Maybe not today
but eventually
hope
but never expect
look forward but never wait
people who do not understand your
silence will never understand your words
sometimes you need to burn Bridges to
stop yourself from Crossing them again
you get what you focus on
so focus on what you want
where you are in a few months depends on
what you do today
never trust a person that has let you
down more than two times
once was a warning twice was a lesson
and anything more than that is simply
taking advantage
don't build your own dream someone will
hire you to build theirs
remember
if you play small you stay small
everything is hard before it is easy
the cost of being wrong is less than the
cost of doing nothing
the more you face challenges the less
you fear them
you have the courage to begin
you have the courage to succeed
things don't happen for no reason
they happen to teach you something
old ways won't open new doors
be patient when becoming someone you
haven't been before
focus on the step in front of you
not the whole staircase
if you don't take risks you will always
work for someone who does
just because it's taking time doesn't
mean it's not happening
you have two choices
evolve or repeat
not all storms come to disrupt your life
some come to clear your path
staying positive does not mean that
things will turn out okay
rather
it is knowing that you will be okay no
matter how things turn out
surround yourself with people who talk
about visions and ideas
not people
sometimes when things are falling apart
they may actually be falling into place
some people are like clouds
when they disappear it's a beautiful day
life is like an elevator on your way up
sometimes you have to stop and let some
people off
weak people Revenge strong people
forgive
intelligent people ignore
the master has failed more times than
the beginner has even tried
only trust someone who can see these
three things in you
the sorrow behind your smile
the love behind your anger
and the reason behind your silence
if your absence doesn't affect them your
presence never mattered
work for a cause not for Applause
live life to express not to impress
what consumes your mind controls your
life
if it doesn't challenge you it won't
change you
admit when you're wrong
shut up when you're right
once you realize you deserve better
Letting Go will be the best decision
ever
always know the difference between what
you're getting and what you deserve
don't be afraid of being different
be afraid of being the same as everyone
else
respect is earned honesty is appreciated
trust is gained
loyalty is returned
you have to fight through some bad days
to earn the best days of your life
the expert in anything was once a
beginner
a truth doesn't cost anything
but a lie could cost you everything
sometimes your circle decreases in size
but increases in value
one day you will wake up and there won't
be any more time to do the things you've
always wanted
do it now
I think there is only one quality worse
than Hardness of Heart
and that is softness of head
foreign
[Music]
pays the best interest
the longer we dwell on our misfortunes
the greater is their power to harm us
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you don't want
drink what you don't like
and do what you'd rather not
never argue with stupid people
they will drag you down to their level
and then beat you with experience
better a broken promise than none at all
if you think you can do a thing or think
you can't do a thing
you're right
don't hit it at all if it is honorably
possible to avoid hitting
but never hit soft
foreign
do what you can with what you have
Where You Are
a gem cannot be polished without
friction
nor a man perfected without trials
a man who suffers before it is necessary
suffers more than is necessary
we should not like sheep follow the herd
of creatures in front of us
making our way where others go not where
we ought to go
we all love ourselves more than other
people
but care more about their opinion than
our own
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
think of yourself as dead
you have lived your life now take what's
left and live it properly
we live only now
everything else is either passed or is
unknown
you are lonely not because no one needs
you
but because you care about who is next
to you
the things you think about determine the
quality of your mind
your soul takes on the color of your
thoughts
learn from who you were
appreciate who you've become and
carefully invest into who you want to be
foreign